as we all know Tate likes to be extreme
and make uh bombastic comments I don't
think that every girl that goes to a
festival is a festival however a lot are
yes okay yeah a lot are it's not you
yeah yeah but we stay out there
um I will say this uh at some point
every woman has to have an epiphany
phase okay now I don't expect women who
are 21 23 25
to not want to go to festivals and not
want to go to concerts and clubs and I
think that's completely unrealistic uh I
think it would be hypocritical for me
that's worked in Nightlife and has hung
out with thousands if not millions of
women in clubs to be like what you doing
up in clubs and festivals so I think
that would be hypocritical